We're gonna start with style today, Ross
because The Guardian's reporting
that the fashion world is expecting a huge boom.
They've already seen an uptick
in clothing and jewelry sales
and they're comparing it to the roaring twenties fashion.
After the 1918 flu in World War 1
the fashion world exploded.
Men switched from suits to sports coats
and women got bobs and put on beaded dresses
and fashion experts expect to see the same joy
and freedom expressed in upcoming trends.
What do you think?
Well, I think people are a couple of things.
One I would love to have somewhere
to go where I could dress up.
It's been a minute, right.
It'd be nice to feel good, get all pretty and go.
The other thing though is I've gotten sort of used
to wearing elastic head to toe 24/7, right?
Yeah.
And so I think that whatever happens
in the fashion world that athleisureness,
where there's that like casual athl-
when you wear stretchy clothes
but you're not going to the gym that's called athleisure.
Yeah.
I think it's all gonna be infused with that.
Like I just got these jeans and they're so stretchy.
I feel like I can put on 20 pounds and still fit in them.
And I have all these pants that are like draw string
and elastic.
I feel like everything's just leaning that way
and I'm fine with it.
Yeah, well, I want people to be on, you know
some form of making their clothes
and their lives a personal billboard.
Because like nature, it goes, you know, underground
and then you have this incredible rebirth
and burst of color and awe.
And I think that we
as humans should embrace and follow in nature's footsteps.
So there is someone out there
in the world who I have been a huge fan of
and following very closely on social media.
He's a young CEO from the UK who founded the very
disruptive global marketing agency called The Social Chain.
And he dropped out of college and became an entrepreneur.
And since then he's done it all against the grain.
And I can't get enough of his insights on Twitter.
Please welcome to the show, Steven Bartlett.
Hi Steven.
(audience applauding)
(chuckling) Hi Drew.
It's a pleasure to be, I mean
that was an amazing set of compliments.
I've been blushing and laughing at the same time.
Thank you so much.
Well, it's true.
I really feel like when I read your posts
I raise an eyebrow
and I'm like, yeah, yeah, that is powerful.
That is some important, wise advice on our behaviors
and we are accountable for our behaviors.
And I really get that from you.
Is that, you know
why do you think that it's important to put
out these messages that you do to people?
Do you know what?
The slightly paradoxical thing is I'm putting out all
of this stuff for myself.
I'm trying to understand myself.
The flaws I have, the toxic traits that I have
and I'm trying to become more self-aware.
And the best way to learn often is to write.
And so I write these things for myself in my diary.
And once in a while, if I can condense it
into something that I think people will understand
and resonate with, I'll share it with the world
and the feedback as well helps me build on the thoughts.
So it's an incredibly selfish pursuit
but I'm so glad to hear
that it's had some value for you.
Everything you just said, I'm like, yeah, yeah
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, ding ding.
(laughing)
Your new book "Happy Sexy Millionaire" is all
about your unique path to success
and it's about to come out and we're so excited for it.
Do you have something that you want a piece of advice
even one piece of advice that you might want people
to take away from your business journey in this book?
Yeah, so the title right?
"Happy Sexy Millionaire".
The reason that the book's called that is at 18 years old
as a very insecure black, broke university dropout,
I wrote in my diary that I wanted
to be a happy sexy millionaire because, well I thought
being a sexy millionaire would make me happy.
And so over the next five years
that's what I strive to become, right.
I built a $200 million global business.
I bought that car that I wrote about in my diary.
I got the girlfriend
because the things that had invalidated me when
I was younger were the things that I inevitably
sought validation from as an adult, as we all do.
And it was in realizing
that it was my insecurities that were driving me
not my intrinsic internal desires,
not the things that I really loved.
That was the moment when I when I was able to turn my life
and really go off to happiness.
And the conclusive point in the book is that in order
to strive for the right things
for the right reasons, you first have to know
that you are enough or you'll make the mistake I did.
And you'll run after the wrong things
for the wrong reason, thinking that pleasure
and external validation equals happiness.
So really the book is about giving you that foundation
that you are already enough.
And that's the foundation
that'll let you chase your best life.
I love that at 18 years old, you're writing happy
sexy millionaire in your diary.
At 18, I wrote, I wanna meet Ginger Spice in my diary.
(laughing)
Did you ever meet her?
I did, actually, I did.
So you know what?
We're sort of the same person, you know, in many ways.
(laughing)
Steven, would you care to join us in a headline?
I'd love to.
We'd be honored.
Ross, take it away.
All right, see well we're starting with a breath
of fresh air and this one comes from automaker giant GM.
That's a big car manufacturer.
Well, Reuters reports that GM is gonna go all electric
by 2035.
And that's a game changer.
It means they'll be phasing
out all new gas and diesel cars and trucks.
And this push to fully eliminate tailpipe emissions came
from GM CEO Mary Barra, who's, you know, the top of the top.
And other companies are expected to follow.
And it's all about the environment
but it's also about the bottom line.
It's about business.
'Cause California announced the sale
of new gas powered vehicles will be illegal starting
in 2035.
Other states are expected to join them.
So if these manufacturers wanna make money
they have to follow these new guidelines
and switch to electric cars.
Now I have had an electric car for a while,
and I know and I was so intimidated to do it.
You know, I wanted to do it for my footprint.
And it quickly became the new normal.
You know, it was confusing at first,
but then I had a friend come over and say,
"Oh, I need to get gas.
"Where's the gas station near your house?"
And I was like, "Oh, I have no idea."
And I think that that's kind of the shift a lot
of us are gonna have to do.
If we wanna save this earth
it's just gotta become the new normal.
But how does it affect the business industry,
you think, Steven?
You know, you've hit the nail on the head in a number
of ways there.
I too used to have this big Range Rover Sport.
That's the car that I wrote about in my diary when I was 18.
I got it at 24.
I sold it at 26 and bought an electric bike instead.
So I now just have an electric bicycle
no other vehicle, right.
I wanna say thank you to General Motors
for recognizing the existential threat
that is climate change.
I wanna say thank you to the legislators,
as you've highlighted, in California for leading the way
and giving them no choice.
And I feel like we should thank Tesla and Elon
because that the singular sort
of company vision they have was to accelerate the advent
of electric vehicles.
Not to win.
To make others catch up with what is inevitably the future.
And so to eliminate this existential threat
which is climate change.
And Steven, I will add to this.
Tesla made it sexy and you know what?
Amen.
That works.
And that's why, you know your book has that word
in it as well.
Sexy sells and it's good.
And that there's nothing
wrong with that.
Amen, amen.
Well.
I completely agree.
I cannot thank you enough, Steven Bartlett
for coming here today.
I am so grateful and.
Thank you so much.
And your new book "Happy Sexy Millionaire" will
be out everywhere tomorrow.
My congratulations.
(laughing)
(applause)
Thank you so much.
Thank you Steven.
(upbeat music)